[Music]
Thank you so much for having me. Thank
you all for being here today and wanting
to learn more about generative media.
Um, I'm going to keep this pretty quick.
There's a lot to show, especially for
some of the new features that we've
released in V3. Um, but there's also a
lot uh to discuss in the in the frame of
how does this revolutionize the way that
people build um things? How do people
create ads? Uh, and how do people
replicate uh some of the experiences
that you might see every day? Um, so as
mentioned, I'm Paige. I am the engine
lead for our Devrell team at Google
DeepMind. Um, but I'm here today on
behalf of our generative media team. Um,
who are all brilliant. Uh, they are
wonderful. uh Tom Hume, Demetri Horn,
many of them uh could not be here today.
Um but uh but this is all their work. So
I just want to send like a thank you to
the heavens for for everything that
they've been building. Um today we're
going to be talking about three
different models. So V3, which is our
new video and audio generation model,
imagine 4, which can generate these
static images, and also LIA 2, which is
a music generation model. Um and stay
tuned, there will be more of all of the
above coming shortly. Um, VO is, uh,
kind of magical in the sense that, you
know, you can create videos of things
that you've never seen before. And we've
saw we've seen some of these examples
already, but it also has the potential
um, to really revolutionize everything
that we build and create as humans. And
I loved this quote from Andre Karpathy
um, just recently that video has the
potential to be an incredible surface
for communication um, but also for
education and for human creativity. So
all of these things are designed with
that in mind. Um V2, I just want to
touch on it briefly before we get into
the V3 capabilities. Um we released a
whole bunch of additional things around
creative control um just recently. So
think on the order of about a month ago
um or not even that. Um so things like
reference powered videos um out pading,
the ability to add and remove objects,
character control and consistency which
I think you uh y'all were talking about
just a little while ago. um and also the
ability to interpolate across first and
last frames. And let's take a look at
what that means. Um because for people
who are not necessarily filmmakers, um
it's much much easier to show and not
tell. Um, so reference powered videos
are things like you have uh you have a
person, you have an environment um and
you're able to kind of put one within
the other or compose them together into
something that um feels very uh very
stylized but also like really really
well um wellcraftrafted. Um so here you
can see reference powered video um with
V2. This is available via the API and
via some of our tools like uh like flow
today.
Uh, and another example of reference
powered video. So, a really really cute
uh little monster in a variety of
environments that you just control by
describing. Um, it's performing pretty
well on benchmarks. So, you can see here
um the green is uh VO. So, um uh
compared to things like runway gen 4 and
cling um the more green the better. Um,
and for reference powered video, most
human raiders um, uh, uh, selected for
VO for some of these sideby-side
comparisons. You can also match styles.
Um, so upload a reference image and then
have, uh, different styles composed
together.
Another example of styles being
preserved. And then also camera controls
the same that you might have if you were
a filmmaker. So things like being able
to move back, move right, um rotate up,
zoom in, um and to be able to precisely
control all of these camera movements.
Again, just via natural language and
through some of the tools that are
available in the APIs. Um when I saw all
of this, I was blown away because I
don't think that we have nearly enough
code samples demonstrating some of these
capabilities. Um but these are all
things that you can do with the V2
models today. Um with the APIs, we also
have the ability to do outpainting. This
was important for uh a recent project
with the sphere around Wizard of Oz. So
being able to take a uh like a a scene
or or an individual frame of a video um
and imagine what the rest of the scene
might look like. So even if you only
have a view into a small portion, um
being able to create something that uh
that looks real um or that looks
consistent uh across the outping
um adding objects or removing objects
from scenes. So you can see here a few
examples as well. Um and again all of
these available for you to test and to
try today. Um, these are all these are
all things that exist um uh that our
that our research team has kind of
gotten into the to the API designs. Um,
some more examples of removing objects.
Character control is quite nice. You
might have seen some of these
demonstrated into your favorite products
um for um kind of controlling mouth
movements, controlling reference space
movements for particular um for
particular characters. We also give the
ability to add a script um and to add
kind of a voice tone and to have the
character um map the lips to producing
that sound and producing it um in a way
that feels consistent with the with the
location. Um these are some of the the
motion examples
um with V2 and with VO3. So being able
to have an input image and controlling
them or changing the design um across
across the scene. Um more benchmarks and
then the first and last frame. Um so you
can have an input image and an output
image and VO is able to interpolate
across them um to to kind of make those
make those images um stitch together
into a video.
And those are just another couple of
examples. I feel like generative media
presentations are very gratifying. Like
these are certainly the most beautiful
things um that we uh that we get to see
at developer conferences.
So V3 everything that you just saw V2 V3
right like like blown away. So V3 is um
video but coupled together with audio.
And so all of the tokens composed
together natively um not audio being
pulled in as a tool um but the model
actually able to compose together all of
these tokens across multiple modalities.
This is similar to what you see with
Gemini's native audio output. Um in
addition to being able to output text
and code, you can also output images,
edit images, and also edit audio,
compose audio, etc. Um, so V3, our
latest state-of-the-art uh video
generation model. Um, it's, uh, you
know, it it has these things around
prompt adherence and native audio
generation. Um, but again, so much
cooler to show, um, and not tell the
little llama.
Then another one that
[Music]
So, so interestingly, you're able to do
not just uh not just uh background
noises, but also things like uh things
like music,
including very very subtle sounds
and the like.
So, let's uh let's go to the next.
There we go. So, so this is hard, right?
Like like uh it looks very cool. It's
very hard to capture the nuances of of
an input prompt. Um and it's also been
really historically very hard to to
preserve visual consistency. Um so
characters often like jump from one um
um from one frame to another. There
might be backgrounds uh and then
suddenly walls disappear and you're able
to see behind them. Um this is one of
the reasons why V3 uh feels like a leap
forward is because the stylistic
consistency and then also the contextual
consistency um is much much better. Um
built on years of research um so things
like GQN um Walt etc. Um and it has
responsibility at its core. So you can
see little uh human visible watermarks
as well as synth ID watermarks um for
synthetically generated images and
video. We've also been partnering really
closely with many many many uh artists
along the way. So uh Darren Areronowski
um also uh musicians for our LIA models,
artists for the imagine models. Um and
we'll take a look at a couple of these
as well. Um so imagine is image
generation. Um uh you know able to kind
of preserve realism. Um everything from
humans to whales uh you know cute
puppies. Um, I've heard that the mo the
more cute puppies that you have in a
presentation, the better it always is.
Um, and then also being able to preserve
detail across all of these images as
well. Um, including diverse styles, uh,
and even things like typography. So, I
love these stamps of Alamo Square and
the Mission. I really, really wish that
we just had these as, um, uh, like swag
ideas that uh, uh, stickers for laptops
or stickers just in general. Um, and uh,
another example of an artist that the
team has been really closely
collaborating with, Ross Lovego, um, on,
uh, on some of his, uh, some of his
designs.
So, uh, LIA 2, um, also very exciting.
It's highfidelity music and professional
grade audio. Um, they also gives you a
very, very granular creative controls.
So the ability to steer the inputs and
outputs and to steer the tones and the
styles of the music um along the way. Um
music AI Sandbox is one of the products
that's been created as a visual for
this. Um if folks are familiar with
Ableton um or things like it uh this
this probably looks uh looks very
similar. Um and then there's also music
effects which is a project from our labs
team uh that allows you to to kind of uh
compose together beats just via natural
language. Um and we use that for the
demo later on today. Uh LIIO real time
uh has also been a deep collaboration
with many musicians um both Jacob
Collier uh who's a legend and uh Toro
Uma um and me circa like uh me circa
college was like blown away that uh Toro
Uma was at Google IO. Um huge fan.
I do think that a big part of teaching
music is giving people a chance to play
music and play with music. However,
people don't have access to the whole of
music from day one. What I think this
offers an interesting perspective into
is the whole of music. Mathematics,
physics, history, geography, the human
body, language, spelling, syntax. One
thing I've come to realize is that a lot
of the same forces that make music work
are the forces that make life work.
Oh, that was not V3. Some parts, but
it's hard to tell, right? Like it's
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. You know, parts of it parts of it
uh might have included uh visuals
generated by VO3, though. Um so, LIIA
again built in collaboration with the
creative industry, um not outside it. uh
and then also incorporates many of these
techniques like synth ID to make sure
that you have some sort of digital
watermarking for the for the assets
themselves. Um so now we're going to get
into it. Uh these are some examples that
I thought might be fun to share to show
just how far we've come in the last
couple of years because I think being
here we get very sucked into the Bay
Area bubble and we don't really kind of
take a step back and appreciate how far
um you know the world has changed in
just a matter of months. Um, so this is
an example of one of the one of the
papers that was produced around 2023.
Um, so released in 2023, research
happening around 2022. Um, for text to
video, a raccoon wearing a black jacket
dancing in slow motion in front of the
pyramids. So just have that in your
brain when you see it. Um, this is Walt
uh, circa 2023. Um, so very very choppy,
like really really hard to have. Um,
even like that's not even 8 seconds
worth of a frame. Um, LTX video from
2024. This is one of the ones that were
available on HuggingFace. Cling 2.0,
which I did with Fall. Um, heck yeah.
Yep. Yeah. So, uh, which I did with
Fall. Um, released in 2025. Uh, and then
V2 2024. Um, a very cute little raccoon,
but I'm not sure how well he's dancing.
Um but this is just kind of a
splattering of how the world has changed
in the space um of just a couple of
years. And then when you put the same
prompt um through V3
um you get this
very stylish raccoon.
So image to video um transforming static
images into dynamic video content. So,
you can see here an image um of a woman
and her puppy. Um a woman I um can only
assume is in Texas um walking very
slowly forward on the way to a gunfight.
Um and also different uh stylized images
of a person in a single frame um being
applied to to different scenarios. So,
running towards the camera um tractor
beam taking off being lifted into the
sky. Again, all steered via natural
language. Um, prompt writing is
something that we've also released in
V3. So, the ability to take that very,
very simple um sentence before of a
raccoon wearing a black jacket dancing
in slow motion in front of the pyramids
um and turn it into something a bit more
fully formed um uh that the VO is is
much better able or better equipped to
understand. Um, and so have that in your
brain. Um, as well as the the concept of
sound generation. So, both music, sound
effects, and background noises. Um, and
we'll take a look at what that simple
prompt um is now.
Wow. I still like get blown away about
how much detail there is like being you
can almost see the reflections in the
eyes um for the for the things as they
as they walk forward. Um and then this
is from our team in Paris. uh and they
are very very excited to have it shared
today. Um does anybody know French in
the audience? Okay, amazing. The rest of
us will have a translation in a second.
Um
[Music]
it's like daffeo
model. It is amazing.
Intelligence artificial
intelligence artificial
artificial
[Music]
And for anyone who is curious, the
translation is um so veo means I see I
see I see in Spanish. Um, and then the
guy responded with, "Yeah, I don't
understand what you're saying because
I'm French actually." Um, artificial
intelligence. Artificial intelligence.
Um, and then, uh, also the that's the
interview. Um, and, uh, boss, the humans
are about to create AGI. Should we
contact them? Um, they're not ready yet.
Uh, so amazing.
Cool. Or actually, I'm going to zoom to
the next zoom to the next one. Uh so how
do you access it? Big question. Um right
now we have a few different ways to
access the VO3 models. One is through
the Google AI ultra plan um which is
available in many different countries um
including the UK just recently. Um the
Google AI pro uh subscribers. So being
able to access via the Gemini mobile app
for a limited number of uses. And then
also VO3 is available in private preview
currently in Vert.Ex AI. V2 also
available via Vert.Ex text AI for the
Gemini APIs. Um hoping to bring them to
AI Studio. Um crossing fingers, but but
we'll see. Um and then you can also fill
out a form for early access if you would
like it. QR code coming shortly. So take
a picture of that if you would like um
with a form to go uh to go submit and
test it out. Um, this is also while
you're looking a code sample of how easy
it is to use um with uh just your output
bucket where you would like the the
video to be deposited. Um if you have an
input image that you want to use as a
starter um some things around aspect
ratios um uh and the like. So um
toggling between different models or
being able to specify some of these is
just a handful of lines of code which is
pretty magical. Um so this was intended
to be a live demo. I'm not sure if I can
tempt the demo gods and also I I'm
probably like close to being overtime.
Um but I wanted to see how well I could
replicate a commercial um with VO that
seemed pretty simple. Um so the
commercial is this one which took my
name. My name's Paige and what makes the
Chick-fil-A chicken sandwich original to
me is the crispiness of the breading and
the tenderness of the fillet. It's
tasty. It's warm. It's total
satisfaction.
Hey, my name's Paige and what makes that
was the that was the input video. Um,
the process for replicating it with V2
is you give Gemini the original video,
have it create a really really detailed
plan. Um, segment into prompts to like
handle the 8-second limitation. Um, used
video uh music effects to create the the
background track which was a combination
of down home farm and slow guitar. Um
and then uh put it all in Camtasia,
stitch it together with transitions.
Whole process uh was relatively quick,
but it also took a lot of thinking and a
lot of work to get to that final
assembly stage. Uh and it looked like
this.
So this is
Hey, my name's Paige. And what makes a
Chick-fil-A chicken sandwich to me is
the crispiness of the breading and a
tenderness of the fillet. It's tasty.
It's warm. It's total satisfaction.
And that was uh again like using uh
using V2, using Gemini text to speech um
and stitching it all together myself.
And I actually like that one better than
the the original commercial, but your
mileage may vary. Process with V3. Um
you have the original video, you
generate the description, you give it to
VO3, and you see how well it does. Um uh
this took uh just the span of like
submitting the prompt to V3. Hey, my
name's Paige and what makes the
Chick-fil-A chicken sandwich original to
me is the crispiness of the breading and
the tenderness of the fillet. So again,
one prompt and was able to produce this.
Hey, my name's Paige and what makes the
Chick-fil-A chicken sandwich to me is
the crispiness of the breading and the
tenderness of the filt.
Incredible. Um, so takeaways, BO3 pretty
magical. We're committed to expanding
it, expanding access as quick as we can,
um, and around uh, adding controls
around durability. Um, and thank you so
much. That is not me actually waving at
the camera. That is a static photo of me
that has been VO3 animated. Excellent.
Thank you.
[Music]